from a familiar Maxim to minimal
maximals and the surprise reveal that
will totally transform the future of the
franchise let's dig into the mechanics
of Rise of the beast's action-packed
ending the climactic Battle of
Transformers rise of the Beast is
triggered by the villainous Scourge
uniting the two pieces of the movie's
main McGuffin which allows them at
various planet-consuming Unicron to make
his way to Earth with only a small
window of time to save this planet the
Autobots robotic animals known as the
maximals and a pair of humans Noah and
Elena all join forces to stop Scourge
this showdown occurring in an isolated
part of a Peruvian rainforest heavily
involves Autobots and maximals checking
it out with a bunch of scourges mindless
minions an army of robotic scorpions as
well as the body's two primary Terracon
allies battle trap and night bird the
drama of this set piece is higher
because the device doesn't only allow
the arrival of Unicron the device that
will bring him to Earth could also bring
Optimus Prime and is also bought
Brethren back to their home planet of
Cybertron in the end Prime after
brutally murdering Scourge makes the
ultimate sacrifice to save earth and its
people by destroying unicron's
interdimensional doorway afterward the
surviving Autobots maximals and humans
all go their separate way ways though
the potential for unicron's return means
that a reunion could someday be in the
cards
while humans and the Transformers have
occasionally been able to temporarily
utilize cybertronian Weaponry to fight
back against Decepticons for the most
part these characters have to leave the
robot skirmishes to Optimus Prime and
company however earlier Transformers
media offered up a solution for how
human beings could fight alongside
robotic Warriors the 1986 feature the
Transformers the movie is one of the
most popular early depictions of an
exosuit in Transformers lore the exo
suit has a robotic armor human beings
can wear that allows them to keep up
with Autobots and Decepticons In the
Heat of battle
come on you could do it
this concept comes a live-action
Transformers movies for the first time
at the ending of Transformers rise of
the beasts a seemingly dying Mirage uses
some of his own parts to give his power
Noah an exosuit that the human can use
to help defeat Scourge Jack Dalton Silva
with hints of blue the rise of the Beast
exosuit allows Noah to take on a
slightly more active role in the
action-packed ending of a Transformers
movie compared to past human
protagonists it also allows vintage
Transformers law to live on in Rise of
the beasts as the source of
crowd-pleasing moments
until all one this phrase was uttered by
Optimus Prime in his final moments
before dying in Transformers the movie
in 1986. since then it's become a
fixture of the franchise with various
incarnations of Optimus Prime and other
Transformers characters uttering it in a
slew of different contexts it becomes a
core phrase in the final half hour of
Transformers rise of the Beast
especially as it pertains to characters
like Optimus Prime and Noah growing more
accustomed to working with others their
initial hesitations that the idea of
human slash Autobot cooperation are
eliminated once Unicron begins to
descend on Earth with the apocalypse
bearing down on them Optimus Prime's
phrase becomes a rallying cry for all
varieties of robots and humans to work
together for a greater
goals all as one Transformers rise of
the Beast users as classic Transformers
phrase to inform its primary theme
emphasizing the importance of unity and
though its ending winds up undercutting
this concept just a little Elena for
instance has sidelined for much of the
climax still it's admirable that
Transformers rise of the Beast Works to
trade some of the cynicism of the
Michael Bay Transformers movies for
something hopeful and long time fans no
doubt got a thrill from hearing the
phrase get revived
Transformers rise of the Beast kicks off
its run time with a prologue depicting a
quartet of maximals escaping their home
planet it's a lengthy sequence
establishing the idea to moviegoers that
these characters will be critical to
everything that will transpire in Rise
of the Beast unfortunately for Beast
Wars fans everywhere the maximals take
forever to return to the movie though at
least they Factor heavily into the plot
once they do show up again the weirdly
subdued presence of the maximals and the
core plot of Rye to the Beast even
extends to the final time audiences see
these characters the maximals are last
shown remaining in their Earth home of
the Peruvian rainforest with Optimus
primal pounding his chest on a cliff as
he Autobots fly away though the story
began Through The Eyes of these
characters as they narrowly avoided
unicron's Horus rise of the Beast just
breezes past the maximals in its ending
the lack of concrete resolution
regarding Optimus Prime will and Pals
will be a strange detail in any context
but it's especially strange given how
right of the Beast initially seems to be
committed to these characters
Prime manages to make a bold sacrifice
to keep Unicron away from Earth the
ending of Transformers rise of the Beast
makes it clear that the villain isn't
finished with his evil machinations
Optimus primal explicitly states that
while Unicron is temporarily thwarted
there's no way he's dead audiences don't
get to explicitly see where Unicron is
hiding out now verse Optimus primal's
word is good enough to know he's still
out there given that Paramount Pictures
is hoping that Transformers rise of the
Beast kicks off a new Trilogy of
Transformers movies it wouldn't be
shocking for Unicron to function as the
overarching antagonist of this new era
of Transformers Cinema the resolution to
unicron's presence in Rise of the Beast
doesn't however offer any Clarity to how
this role in this movie reconciles with
the previous depiction of Unicron in the
live-action Transformers movies the 2017
installment Transformers The Last Knight
explicitly revealed that the planet
Earth is actually Unicron who's been
dormant for eons but begins to rise
again in the film's climax Earth is
Unicron one day his horns will rise to
fight the Mad goddess given that
comments on the rise of the Beast
creative team indicate this new movie is
still meant to be in continuity with
earlier live action Transformers fare
it's peculiar the wrap up to unicron's
plotline doesn't offer any Clarity for
how two wildly different versions of
this planet gobbling body can exist in
the same franchise
while there's uncertainty about whether
maximals and Unicron go next in the
ending of Transformers rise of the Beast
the Blockbuster is much more clear about
the fates of its two human protagonists
nowhere for one heads back to his
apartment after saving the world giving
his mom and younger brother a big hug
though he's now fought alongside robots
family is clearly as important as ever
for Noah and the final moments of Rise
of the beasts even focus on him going in
for a job interview so he can ship in
around the house while waiting for that
interview Noah spies something on a
nearby TV that offers a resolution for
Elena's plotline on this TV Noah
Witnesses a commercial for a forthcoming
60 Minutes interview with Elena who has
become a famous archaeologist based on
her discoveries in Peru her work
previously helped the Autobots save the
world and now she finally has a chance
to be seen as a Titan in her profession
she's come a long way from the earlier
scenes in Rise of the Beast where she
was just an intern at a museum
struggling to get the attention of her
superiors in the wake of their first
adventure with robotic life forms both
Noah and Elena judging by the ending of
Transformers rise of the beasts of
managed to carve out truly satisfying
lives
safer bumblebee each of the live-action
Transformers movies have ended similarly
in voice over narration Optimus Prime
gives a commanding speech that
encapsulates the themes of the preceding
movie that offers some hope for the
future even after the tremendous losses
incurred in a battle with the forces of
evil but the day will never come that we
forsake this planet we hope to see you
again
I do not know Transformers rise
of the Beast offers up a bit of a tweak
to this formula though not at the
expense of a new Optimus Prime speech
like the first five Transformers movies
voice actor Peter Cullen belts out a big
monologue as Optimus Prime but this time
he's not the only one delivering a
speech once Prime's words are finished
Noah begins to deliver his own final
speed through narration while also
displaying a balance between the past of
the Transformers movies and new
flourishes if this Saga wants to
continue as a major part of the
Blockbuster movie landscape that means
subverting expectations even when it
comes to Transformer Staples like
Optimus Prime's closing speech
the final pre-credits scene of
Transformers rise of the Beast ends of
Noah going in for a job interview with a
seemingly ordinary businessman however
that man quickly reveals that he knows
about the autobots and how Noah has
saved the world this guy and his
references to working for a larger
organization initially make it appear
that Noah is talking to someone from
sector 7 The Secret Agency from
Transformers and Bumblebee however a
business card from the mysterious
stranger reveals a real organization
Noah has come into contact with GI Joe
yes Transformers writer the Beast tease
up not just sequels but a big Cinematic
Universe fixated and Hasbro properties
like Transformers and GI Joe it's
unclear what a big screen Union between
these two adaptations would even look
like and the brief glimpses of a base
belonging to this universe's version of
GI Joe doesn't Inspire much confidence
for the visual possibilities of a
crossover still the ending of
Transformers rise of the beasts makes it
apparent that the future of the Autobots
on the big screen will involve working
with at least the GI Joe universe and
almost certainly other Hasbro properties
while the GI Joe twist has massive
implications for future Hasbro movies
the mid-credits scene of Rise of the
Beast isn't anything too memorable it's
a predictable gag that would have been
underwhelming even if it didn't come hot
off the heels of a big crossover tease
the scene depicts Noah introducing his
licorice fixated friend reeked to his
new car I repainted and modified version
of mirage's automobile form after we can
make some derogatory comments about how
the vehicle isn't anything special
Mirage transforms into his robot form
and talks back to reek it's clear what
the punchline of this comedic scene will
be from frame one while the
overabundance of Davidson's comedic
stick and the rest of Rise of the Beast
makes it unlikely any moviegoers were
clamoring for even more of the character
this mid-credits rise of the Beast
sequence would have been better served
coming before the big GI Joe tease but
truth be told there was no place was in
the movie that would have made this
scene instantly hysterical
the ending of Transformers rise of the
Beast makes it clear that Paramount
Pictures and Hasbro have grand plans for
the Transformer Saga to finally cross
over with Hasbro properties but what
exactly future Standalone Transformers
movies will look like is much more
unclear rise of the Beast is content to
tell a largely Standalone story that
mostly exists in harmony as a prequel to
The earlier Michael Bay Transformers
features even with the Ambitions of
using rise of the Beast as a springboard
for a Trilogy of Transformers Adventures
it's not instantly apparent just what
aspects of the dense Transformers Mythos
or Nextbook and relevant there's
something Primal in each of us this is
an interesting deviation from the last
two Michael Bay Transformers movies age
of Extinction and The Last Knight Each
of which ended on major Cliffhangers and
made it clear what the leaping off point
for direct sequels would be Beyond's the
likely return of Unicron though rise of
the Beast sets its sights on teasing a
larger Cinematic Universe rather than
endlessly hinting at where further
Standalone Transformers movies will go
next either way the lengthy history of
these live-action Transformers movies
indicates that this franchise won't be
going anywhere anytime soon